a new round of budget talks over the
weekend failed to end the partial
government shutdown it's now tied for
the second longest in US history some
800,000 federal workers are wondering
when they'll see their next paycheck the
White House claims it made concessions
in the standoff with congressional
Democrats President Trump is standing
firm on his demand for 5.7 billion
dollars to pay for a wall but now he's
asking for 800 million for humanitarian
needs at the border major Garrett is at
the White House where the president is
also talking about bypassing Democrats
in Congress major good morning good
morning the president has no public
events on his schedule today and no
negotiations are planned with
congressional Democrats either involving
President Trump or senior White House
staff the work talks over the weekend
but they didn't appear to accomplish
much and all that Washington can a pair
can appear to agree on now is that this
deal is a long long way away it is
national security it's a national
emergency
president Trump insisted he won't let
Democrats build a political barrier to
block construction of a border wall a
presidential emergency declaration might
allow mr. Trump to divert Pentagon funds
to accelerate construction of the wall
but Democrats balked I think the
president would be wide open to a court
challenge saying where's the emergency
despite stalled weekend readings the
president called the process productive
they don't like concrete so we'll give
him still mr. Trump's latest offer now
calls the wall a steel barrier but the
White House has not budged from the
price tag 5.7 billion dollars it also
wants more funds for Border Patrol
agents immigration judges and detention
beds House Speaker Nancy Pelosi told CBS
Sunday morning the president isn't
interested in negotiating he would like
to not only close government build a
wall but also abolish Congress so the
only voice that mattered was his own the
president acted as if he could we're top
Democrats down Schumer and Nancy Pelosi
and myself can solve this in 20 min
if they watch it if they don't want to
it's going to go on for a long time our
mortgage gas-electric a long time
without pay for more than 800,000
federal workers like these prison guards
in Massachusetts we're not getting paid
and the risk is the same the president
was asked if he can relate to the pain
of federal workers living paycheck to
paycheck
I can relate and I'm sure that the
people that are or the receiving end
will make adjustment they always do this
shutdown affects more than federal
workers and federal contractors if no
resolution is reached by the end of this
month more than 40 million Americans who
rely on food stamps will not receive
that federal assistance to feed their
families in Viana there'll be nothing
partial about the shutdown for them well
let's get more into the ripple effects
here major there's no end to the
shutdown in sight right now as you
mentioned more and more Americans will
soon be directly affected by it who else
is going to start feeling the effects as
it drags on interestingly the Internal
Revenue Service will keep gathering tax
money but not we working on tax refunds
for the tax season unless there's
funding for the Treasury Department TSA
has seen more sick calls coming in there
are more stress on national parks and
the food stamps we mentioned and as well
there'll be other federal agencies
feeling the effects
the longer the shutdown goes on yeah I
read reports this morning that some
furloughed workers are resorting to
being uber drivers as well major the
effects are really being felt thank you